McDonald's was a prominent part of many
childhoods
for many these toys bring back memories
and these toys are still making memories
for children today make sure you watch
this video until the end to know which
movie inspired the most popular toys if
this is your first time visiting the
channel don't forget to subscribe and
please give this video a big thumbs up
today we are showing you the 10 best
toys ever given in a McDonald's Happy
Meal beanie babies every 90s kid knows
what beanie babies are and they probably
owned at least 20 the wildly popular
plush animals were first created in 1983
but roasts popularity in the early 90s
beanie babies quickly became collectors
items making them not only popular with
kids but with adults as well beanie
babies came with the heart-shaped tags
often attached to their ears and inside
the tags were the animal's name and date
of birth
many serious collectors and some
children bought plastic protectors to go
around the tag so as not to potentially
decrease the value of the beanie baby
this intense popularity made the beanie
baby a perfect candidate for McDonald's
toys these were called teeny babies
these beanie babies were much smaller
than the original but of work just as
cute they were first released in 1997
and continued to be offered on and off
until 2000 according to one of our
sources when the teeny babies were
released in 1997 it was thought that
McDonald's had planned to give away a
hundred million in five weeks but it
actually took two weeks in 2017 beanie
babies somewhat resurfaced but as a more
modern version called beanie boos beanie
boos featured different animals and
characters like dragons and ghosts but
they look much more cartoony than their
predecessors with giant colorful eyes
it's nice that children today will get
to experience the beanie babies but we
wonder if they'll ever be as popular as
they once were
Ronald McDonald toys as it turns out
McDonald's have their own fictional
characters Ronald McDonald is obviously
the primary mascot of the fast food
chain he's the clown that is often
featured in McDonald's TV advertisements
other characters include grimace the
Hamburglar and birdie the early
bird did you know these characters
inhabit a fictional land called
McDonnell and these characters have
appeared in Happy Meals multiple times
over the years if you were to search
Ronald McDonald toys on ebay you would
find many vintage toys typically the
toys would be small hard plastic
figurines where you could sometimes
maneuver their arms and legs these toys
were definitely meant to be more
collectible then used for playing if you
look at the ronald mcdonald toys
throughout the years you might get a
little creeped out by some of them
especially the ones with ronald we're
not sure if there was ever a creepier
Happy Meal toy released but what makes
them so special is that they're classic
vintage Happy Meal toys the toys
themselves reflect the history of
McDonald's franchise through the
different generations of Ronald Happy
Meals you can see the images have
transformed over the years that being
said these toys are worth virtually
nothing many on eBay are being sold for
under $10 most likely this is because
they are mass produced and distributed
toys but maybe in a few years when
they're really vintage he'll be worth
something who knows sky dancers you
might not all remember sky dancers sky
dancers started out as a toy where you
have a plastic fairy looking girl with
wings on a launch pad and when you
pulled the cord attached to the launch
pad the fairy would spin and fly for a
few seconds explained like this the toy
might not sound is too exciting but it
was very popular for some time so
popular that an animated series video
game and several books were written
about the sky dancers the sky dancers TV
series first aired in 1996 the show's
main characters are high school students
from high hope dance academy and they
were called upon by Queen Scylla to
protect the kingdom it might not be that
surprising to know that the series was
cancelled after season 1 although
according to one of our sources it was
canceled after educational and
informative TV regulations came into
effect we wonder if it was canceled
because of the regulation change or if
people lost interest quickly nonetheless
sky dancers were still popular enough to
make it as McDonald's feature Happy Meal
toy the toys appear to have been
featured at McDonald's in 1997 and from
the pictures of people's Mickey sky
dancer collections there appears to have
been four to six fake
offered they all appear to be girls as
this toy was for young girls even though
there were two male sky dancers in the
TV series is this something you would
play with today Hot Wheels cars Hot
Wheels cars have been popular for as
long as we can remember even the
commercials are memorable and I'm sure
most adults and teens can recall that
the commercials usually featured young
boys racing the Hot Wheels cars around
the track there was usually dramatic
music some flames and animation in real
life the car racing tracks were still
fun but it was never how it looked in
the commercial but obviously people
loved Hot Wheels because the company has
been around since 1968 and is still
going the first time McDonald's included
Hot Wheels in their happy meals was in
1983 McDonald's continued to distribute
the same type of Hot Wheels until 1990
in 1991 McDonald's designed their own
Hot Wheels cars and included them in
their happy meals
Hot Wheels has seen a lot of
transformation since their release more
than 45 years ago today there's a lot of
variety of cars there are collections
like Super Mario and Batman and you can
go on their website and play Hot Wheels
games online in addition since Hot
Wheels have been around for so long and
many types have been discontinued some
of these cars are worth thousands in
particular the hot pink 1969
rear-loading Volkswagen Beach bomb is
said to be worth 72 thousand dollars and
it may be the only one in the world good
luck in your search for the hot pink
Volkswagen Disney Princesses almost
every young girl went through the phase
of wanting to be a princess when they
grew up this fantasy probably stemmed
from the plethora of Disney Princess
movies these movies also tended to be on
repeat for some girls some of those og
princesses include
Snow White the very first Disney
Princess Cinderella Aurora Ariel Belle
and jasmine some of the most modern-day
princesses in the Disney franchise are
Merida Rapunzel Anna and Elsa it's not a
surprise that McDonald's would want to
team up with Disney for their Happy Meal
toy collection the princesses are
consistently popular characters for
Disney Disney Princess movies almost
always do extremely well in theaters
and children love them for years
afterwards many adults still have a
favorite Disney Princess with Disney
coming out with a new movie with
princesses almost every year
McDonald's is guaranteed to have a
successful Happy Meal toy Happy Meal
toys also sometimes come out while the
movie is in theaters this is a great
promo for the movies and for McDonald in
2002 McDonald's paired up with Disney
for their hundred years of magic
campaign where Mickey's will release a
hundred different Disney Happy Meal toys
in that collection included Pocahontas
Snow White and all her dwarves Ariel
Cinderella and many more that really is
what dreams are made of next time a new
Disney movie comes out make sure to
check out MacDonnell's to see if your
favorite character is available play-doh
some of you played with it when you were
kids and some of you ate it
play-doh surprisingly is a very
interesting history did you know that
play-doh started out as a wallpaper
cleaner it was discovered in the early
1950s a certain kind of wallpaper
cleaner would be great as a child's toy
once the popularity became apparent the
wallpaper cleaning company made a switch
to a toy company officially calling it
play-doh in 1956 it's not crazy that
what is now a phenomena and has been for
a long time what started out as a
wallpaper cleaner one of our sources
says the recent estimates say pet kids
have played with 700 million pounds of
play-doh we can't even begin to imagine
what this would look like McDonald's
obviously picked up this toy to feature
in their Happy Meal in 1983 there were
packs of play-doh that were likely to
not even be large enough to make
anything other than a small ball plato's
relationship with McDonald's didn't in
there
play-doh and McDonald's paired up to
make play-doh set that was sold in
stores and the set included molds for
kids make fries nuggets burgers and
milkshakes we would not be surprised if
after playing with the set at home kids
begged their parents to go eat at the
real thing right after we also wouldn't
be surprised if the kid just filled up
on their play-doh fries Tamagotchi
the Tamagotchi taught kids everywhere
how to be responsible and take care of
another being although once schools
banned them many parents did end up
having to take care of them or they
didn't
your Tamagotchi was replaced with an
angel egg while you were in English
class before they were banned though
millenials carried them around on their
necks on a lanyard often storing more
than one so what was once a toy was also
a fashion trend and even though
Tamagotchis themselves were the bomb the
McDonald's toy didn't quite live up to
the real thing they were smaller
versions in keychain form which meant
that kids that didn't have a Tamagotchi
could still pretending had one or feel
like they did zapping the old Tamagotchi
shells could be open to reveal an
adorable Tamagotchi character so you
could either clip the shell or the
character onto your backpack it's too
bad the Happy Meal Tamagotchis weren't
functioning but it makes sense as a
functioning Tamagotchi retailed for
about $25
so McDonald's probably couldn't include
the real version if your never had a
Tamagotchi you are really missing out
and you should probably try to buy one
of the relatively affordable ones off
eBay just this year Bandai the company
who makes Tamagotchis will be releasing
their 1997 versions of Tamagotchis if
you can get your hands on that do it
emoji smiley toys the McDonald's emoji
smiley toys is one of the most recent
Happy Meal toys on the list before
emojis were emoticons and before
emoticons there were just colons and
round brackets actually we can't
remember that far back anyway those cute
little emojis used to express emotions
and replace words basically they can
help spice up your text a little bit the
great thing about emojis too is how many
there are of them you can literally
choose from hundreds and whereas with
earlier forms emojis you basically have
the option between different Smiley's
and a heart and now there are animals
people building in sports you name it
so obviously McDonald's had to hop on
the bandwagon and give their version of
emoji Smiley's and a Happy Meal these
Happy Meal toys were plushies smiley
faces with expressions similar to that
of the most popular smiley emojis he
didn't do much but we suppose you could
cuddle with them and most likely many
kids had a collection going much to the
dislike of their parents not the parents
dislike emojis but they tend to dislike
unnecessary clutter or was that just our
parents anyway with more and more emojis
added every year we're sure McDonald's
will have to repeat this Happy Meal toy
or at least do something some
again Furby the Furby Happy Meal toys
sometimes called Nick Furby is one of
the most beloved McDonald's toys the
popularity of this McDonald's toy most
likely stems from the popularity of the
original Furby doll the original Furby
was released in 1998 the 12 months
following its release a total of 27
million Furbies were sold that's a lot
of Furbies the original Furby was hard
plastic that had plush furry exterior it
had wide somewhat creepy eyes and a beak
that would open and shut the furbies
ears also could wiggle up and down the
toy was advertised with the slogan the
more you play the more they say the
commercial showed kids trying to teach
their Furby their own names and the
names of the owners strangely enough the
toy was advertised almost as a baby doll
toy even though the Furby looked like
some kind of space alien or gremlins
the McDonald's Furbys which were given
out in Happy Meals from March 26 to a
predict they didn't talk or move on
their own
but if you pressed a button their ears
eyes toes and their beaks would move not
that McDonald's version was also maybe a
bit less creepy looking than the real
thing so perhaps it would be a good
alternative if your Furby was giving you
nightmares
but he still wanted to fit in
unfortunately or maybe fortunately the
Furby trend went away pretty fast and it
seems to be unlikely that it will come
back anytime soon Toy Story Toy Story is
a Disney Pixar phenomenon well known to
Millennials the first movie was released
in 1995 and is about toys who when their
owner Andy is asleep come to life
woody Andy's favorite feels jealous when
Buzz Lightyear's
added to Andy's toy collection but by
the end they becomes good friends there
are three toy story movies and they all
follow the adventure of these toy
characters with Buzz and Woody being the
main protagonists when Toy Story 3 was
released in 2010 the younger generations
got to learn about the exciting
Adventures of Woody and Buzz following
the 1999 release of Toy Story 2
McDonald's released their collection of
Toy Story toys Toy Story is a beloved
Disney Pixar movie so it was no surprise
that the McDonald's toys were popular
too toy story 2 was particularly
exciting because the new characters
would introduce
including Jessie Jessie is a female
cowgirl which added a female to toy
story's main protagonists the young
girls love Jessie because she was a
daring and fun female character the Toy
Story happy milk characters were small
figurines with movable parts like legs
and arms there would have been a big
incentive to collect all the toys
because then you could have Andy's toy
collection and play with all of them
like in the movies did we miss any of
your favorite McDonald's Happy Meal toys
let us know in the comments below thanks
for watching and that's it for the best
toys ever given in McDonald's Happy
Meals if you want to see more stories
like this make sure you watch 15 hidden
images in logos you never noticed you'll
be surprised at why the golden arches
are used as the McDonald's logo thanks
for watching
[Music]